i feel like people who are warning about
the dangers of wokism
and those who warn about the apocalypse
of climate change walk a similar path
has anti-woke already fallen into the
trap of sounding too hyperbolic to be
honest
well the question seems to assume uh
that we will be on board with the idea
that
uh climate change could be apocalyptic
as hyperbole
which um we we aren't we don't agree
with the fact that we
uh question some of the models
that have been generated um that the
conclusions of which
are part of what the evidence is for
there being a possible climate change
apocalypse on the horizon
does not mean um that we can't also
point to a considerable amount of
evidence uh suggesting that we've got a
real problem
and um that there is really no excuse
for
not fixing that problem quickly and in
fact you know i'm
i'm proud of what we've done on dark
horse talking about
the evidence that there is something
very serious and novel going on
including
yama craters including glacial retreat
um and the uh plumes of co2 being
released
we've also talked about the fascinating
and possibly
very positive sign um that there may be
a negative feedback that retards the
release
of uh of methane from the arctic as a
result of sea level rise creating
greater pressure that holds
uh the the clathrates stably
um and you know so yes there's
hyperbolic stuff in the climate stuff
and the more model based it is the
greater the number of bodies that can be
buried on the other hand there's stuff
you can
check yourself and the fact is i think
all of us who have lived
you know in places for long enough to
monitor
uh the trends know that something is
changing now do things change without
human beings they do
but it's changing in a predicted
direction it is concordant with
uh a reduction in glaciers etc now the
changes are speeding up
yeah the changes are speeding up on the
other hand you know kilimanjaro should
be
free of glaciers by now and it isn't
right so
this gives you an ability to calibrate
what you really need to be careful of
though
is that the positive feedbacks can take
you from one place to some place
way down the road very very quickly and
so
you know really i have my eye very
closely
on the danger of a positive feedback
with respect to methane release from the
arctic that is where this is going to
get
uh away from us right quick but we have
no
no known breaks no no possible no this
will take us this will take it
completely out of human control
and so anyway you know i'm not looking
forward to when i told you so on that
front we need to stay far short of that
which means we need to
you know we need to do all kinds of
things i've advocated for uh
us uh you know going full speed ahead to
get fusion
power because fusion power is the one
technology that would actually allow us
to reverse global warming not just halt
it but reverse the process
um so you know if you get nothing else
from this
i would argue that is a nuanced
i think balanced presentation of the
various things that belong in that
analysis and you are right
when one enters climate uh change
circles you very often get
only you know you get uh confirmation
bias
across the entire landscape and that's
not reasonable anti-scientific
conversational tone
right and it is in it is certain to be
true that to the extent that there will
be data that goes both ways and there
will of course be data that goes both
ways that the field is inhospitable
to the data that goes against its
central conclusion you won't find it
published right even
even if there are and there surely are
many many many good and honest
scientists who find
things that they didn't expect and don't
really it doesn't match their
understanding of the universe even if
they are trying to get those things
published
it's probably harder and harder to do so
right yeah
so in any case there's a nuanced way to
do this
the field is not being good about it
that is dangerous in and of itself
the parallel between climate and
woke-ism
i'm leery of but i would say yeah we've
said from the beginning
there's an element of truth right that
you know for example what we said a few
minutes ago about
um that there is a lot of stuff
downstream of slavery and jim crow
that has impact today that's not the
same thing as saying
racism is rampant today right right it's
saying the consequences of past racism
are still with us
which is a very different conversation
so yes you know nuance in all things
where
nuance is reasonable yeah
[Music]